uh
okay it looks like we are live
so you'll
i'm just going to tweet out real quick
that we're going live
okay sweet all done
okay so i'm gonna put on my glasses
as you guys can probably tell by the
title of today's video
in today's video i'm going to be talking
about
how i create my youtube videos using
blackmagic products um
and i'm doing this hey
hey norm blackmagic crew i'm doing this
live primarily because i think that
doing this live would be
the best way for me to illustrate kind
of
the functionality of some of their
products so
i'll be viewing chat a little bit
but mostly this is going to be me work
talking through
my workflow how i create videos the
hardware and software side of things so
hopefully some of you guys find this
useful
this is actually kind of a really
emotional
subject for me and
that's because as a writer
i've found that things that inspire me
are things that i have to pay attention
to so if i see a good
movie or if i if i hear a song that
really hits home with me
i i've learned that over the years
trying to do creative
writing as as my main profession
that when i pay attention to things like
that
that enables me to kind of
reflect those same kind of emotions
through my writing
now when i started doing youtube one of
the things i had to search for obviously
was a camera and i went through
all the different uh you know major
japanese camera companies so
sony panasonic nikon canon etc
and i saw each of their
you know their cameras and they they all
seemed you know
more more than adequate but oh i'm a
little bit quiet okay i'll turn up my
mic a little bit
okay hopefully hopefully that's a little
bit better now
as i was searching for cameras one of
the cameras that i found
was this camera
and this is called the black magic
pocket cinema camera this came out and i
want to say
about 2013 or maybe 2014 maybe
around then and um
when i saw the images that the cam this
camera produced
it felt like art to me i saw this video
of it was a night scene at like a fair
that was shot using raw cinema dng
raw footage shot on this camera and it
immediately
struck me as just beautiful it felt
fundamentally different
than any of the other cameras that i've
been searching for at this point
and i know this sounds cheesy i know
this sounds like you know i'm being paid
to say this and blackmagic
did send out many of the items that
you're about to see
but that's why i ended up buying you
know
this camera is because i looked at that
video and i
i thought oh my gosh this looks like
like film this doesn't look like
digital video this looks like beautiful
film
and so i decided okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna use this camera to create my my
youtube videos
and i bought it used on
uh ebay i think for like 400
in 2015 2000 yeah 2015 when i started
doing my
my youtube videos and
i've been using it ever since and it's
never really failed but
today i'd like to talk about how i use
this product
and and this product and the other
things that you're about to see
effectively to speed up my workflow as a
youtuber and again we're kind of doing
this live to illustrate
how many of how some of these products
work so the first thing i'm going to do
now
is
i'm a little bit late is he talking
about a camera band brand or an editing
program i'm talking about every
everything so i'm talking about how i
use my camera how i
apply color grading
many many different things so
let's see i'm going to turn
maybe maybe i can leave this up actually
that's okay
so what i'm going to do now is i'm going
to hook this camera up
live and kind of show you guys
the second product that i'm currently
used to lives to live stream
so we're going to hook this camera up
right here
to this little mount that i have here
and point it down kind of at my desk
and hook up two of these cables that i
have right here and again
i think the fact that we're doing this
live is kind of it speaks to how
how powerful these things are so i'm
going to turn that on now
okay now that's that's currently on and
let's see
now i'm going to switch to this camera
and this is the camera that we just
hooked up
so let's go back to the main camera
oops so this is my main camera and i
just hooked up
this second camera right here so and
what you're seeing
through this camera in this little
window on the bottom right side of the
screen right here
this product right here this is called
the atem mini pro
and this is many different things but
it's an hdmi switcher but it's also kind
of like a
mini tiny computer that's built
specifically for streaming
and camera switching so
obviously i can do what i just did i can
if i press a button on this
device as you can see again in this
bottom bottom right
hand of the screen i can cycle through
the various things that are hooked up to
it
so i can make that my main screen that
you guys are seeing i can make this
the main screen that you guys are seeing
one of the reasons that i really like
this product
is because um i'm not a big fan
of programs like obs i've found that
they tend to
crash and they're very finicky
so i i much prefer to have dedicated
hardware
that allows that allows me to stream oh
hey eric
and and kylie as well
glad to see you uh pop in yeah the color
is a little bit bleak on this
but we'll actually be talking about that
in a second as well
so i'm going to kind of go through my
entire workflow now
and talk about how i how i speed things
up but
um let's let's turn this off real
quickly
and maybe just for a little bit of
variety we'll switch out the lens on
this camera real quick
with this super wide lower lens so
this will make things look immediately
different and maybe hopefully cooler
although you might see the crappy uh
uniqlo like
sweatpants that i'm wearing so let's
switch out the camera lens
do a shot okay now we're completely
white
and you should still be able to hear me
but let's hook up that lens now
bam now we're immediately much wider so
this is kind of a cool shot as well
i like that i like this kind of
shot it's you know kind of more dynamic
okay now let's talk about
color grading and luts i think that's
probably probably the best
best way to describe things um before
before doing that i just got to change
something real quickly
within this software okay so now
i'm going to switch to the camera that i
i use
for my my normal comedic videos on
youtube so
as you guys know this is this is the
setup that i use
on on on youtube
and the image looks kind of ridiculous
right now like it looks
really really white and really really
washed out
way over saturated really kind of
unusable is probably the best way to
describe
it and that's because if you know
anything about
color grading
if you shoot video that looks good
already then it's difficult to change
the colors
of that video after the fact so
what you're seeing right now on this
camera this is kind of a
custom look that i created and then
baked into the the camera so i'm going
to
switch this camera right now
back to what it looks like by default so
you guys can see
so i'm going to pop off camera real
quick but i'll do this
do this quickly hopefully
okay
so this is kind of what my my camera
looks like
by default and as you can probably tell
it looks
i would say significantly worse right
now than it did a second ago
and the reason for that is because again
the built-in colors are often kind of
what the camera company thinks are going
to be best for
every general scenario but what i've
gone ahead and done
is created a lot specifically for
this particular camera and this
particular setup so
right now you know the the japanese
paper walls they they look
white and uh the entire image kind of
looks a little bit yellow maybe because
the
white balance might be off but
now i'm going to switch back to that
that other look that i created again
specifically for
this camera so let's switch back
okay and we're back so obviously this
looks i think
much better much more cinematic and one
of the amazing things about this camera
this black magic pocket cinema camera 4k
is that you can build you can bake luts
into the into the camera into the image
being produced by the camera so i'm
going to get a little bit technical here
and i know that many many of you guys
are a little bit
and yeah like this looks like a lot more
blue and blue and
yellow that's kind of good complementary
colors
so obviously if you're doing youtube
you want to make the image look kind of
as dynamic
and interesting as possible i think
that's
that's safe to say but again if i go
back to
my normal camera as you can see
from my normal comedic video this looks
really really really washed out
and this is because this image for my
comedic setup
it's called a log file
and log files are well
they look terrible when you haven't done
anything
to them but a log file
is really really easy to edit
in post-production so on the computer
side of things
yeah so like fujifilm fuji has really
good colors but
like let's say you bought like a fuji
camera um
and you a lot of people say fujifilm has
fuji has some of has some of the best
colors but what if you
you didn't like it that much what if you
wanted to make things like
like what i just did maybe you wanted to
make this a little bit more
blue for example and you wanted to kind
of adjust the colors a little bit
if the image already looks good then
it's very difficult
to adjust the colors after the fact
so that's why people shoot with this
kind of log
image because when you shoot like this
then
it's very easy to make the image look
like what you want it to look like
when you're editing the image so what
i'm going to do now
is i'll tell you what we'll go to
do
i'm going to go ahead and go to
my computer screen
and go over here
this is the control one of the ways that
i can control
the a10 mini pro that we saw earlier so
so this thing
i'm using this device to currently
stream and i can do some advanced things
like change the size of
uh this this
window that you're currently looking at
in the bottom right corner
yeah so the video has to look bad to
look good in pro
in post production yes that's the
perfect way to describe it
if you're trying to make the video look
a certain way that is
but again tell you tell you what we'll
do let's go to one of my projects
i recently made a video called 34 signs
that you're in japan
so let's open that project up
and you guys can see i use final cut pro
to edit my videos
and if i click final cut oh
okay oh that that should be off though
okay i just want to make sure that the
uh
so when you
are creating a let me let me mute my
computer real quick
okay so we're back in the timeline right
now i'm going to mute my computer but
again when i'm making a video
um this this is what it looks like
within
final cut pro and this image that you're
seeing up here
this is what it looks like
when a color grade has already been
applied to the image
but let's see what it looks like before
a color
grade is applied so we're going to click
on this we're going to go up to the
video settings
we're going to disable these effects
real quick
so now the image looks completely
different right and
again this is what the image looks like
this is what the image looks like out of
camera but because it looks like this
it gives me the ability to pull the
image around
and make me look like make it look like
what i want it to look like when i'm
editing the video
so if i click this again
now it looks entirely different so i've
i've applied a balance
a color balance i've applied color
wheels i've applied a custom
lut a look up table and i've also
adjusted the skin tones a little bit
but let's say that it wasn't going for
this particular kind of look
this is my comedic look as many as many
of you guys know
but i'm going to turn this off i'm going
to delete all these
and let's color grade this video as if i
was going to make a phonetics
video so for my phonetics videos my in
which i teach japanese pronunciation
using my knowledge of japanese i go for
a different look i go for a look that's
a little bit more
bright and what i'd like you guys to do
because this is kind of critical in
explaining everything
is when i apply this color grade
phonetics color grade to this clip
okay you see this dotted line up here
that appeared above the clip
this is the computer now rendering
this file so the computer
is processing this new color grade and
it finished but
if we make this particular clip very
very long
then it takes the computer a very very
long time to
to process this whole this whole uh
particular clip with these colors so
what that means is if i shoot a
if i shoot like a 60 minute video
then i apply the color grade so that i
can see what it looks like and then i
choose the looks or the individual takes
that i like from there
that means that i have to wait about 20
minutes or so for the finish
for for the video to finish rendering
obviously as a creator that's a lot of
time kind of
waiting for things to happen and you can
do other things during that time like
you can
you know check your email do accounting
that kind of thing but
because color correction and rendering
so making the video
again look like this
changing the way that a video looks is
very
intensive on the computer's processor
and graphics card
sometimes what happens is
yeah you can see the chat the computer
will crash
so you what i like to do is when i'm
rendering out the video is i let the
video just render out and that takes
again about 20 minutes or so
so again earlier when i talked about why
the fact that you can change you can
choose your own custom
lut and bake it into the footage coming
out of this particular camera
that's really really powerful because it
it means that you don't have to render
the video
in post production you can get
completely rid of that 20 minutes or so
of waiting for the computer to apply the
color grade
so that's 20 minutes gone right
so that's that's a very very big deal
but this is this is where things kind of
start to get a little bit interesting
and i know that this is like super
technical but um
i'm i'm really passionate about this
because as a creator
the little things that you can do to
speed up your workflow
make a very very big difference in the
long run
so as i talked about earlier
this this is the comedic image coming or
this is the
the image coming out of my my pocket
cinema camera that i used to create my
youtube videos right as i think most of
you guys probably know
but unfortunately because
this image is coming out of a very old
camera
this older camera doesn't have the
ability to
bake the lut into the footage to bake
that color correction into the footage
the same way that
newer camera does now this
is kind of like my inner artist talking
so to speak but
i personally prefer the look of the
older camera
over the newer camera because it looks a
little bit more kind of
grainy so to speak it's a little bit um
it looks a little bit more film-like in
my own personal opinion
so rather than going out and buying a
1 300 camera just to get rid of that 20
minutes or so
of waiting for the color correction to
apply i just said i'm just going to keep
on continuing to use this particular
camera and i'll just continue to wait
while the while the video is rendering
when i'm doing my video editing
however i became aware recently
of another product
i'll show you guys now it's called
the mini converter sdi
to hdmi 6g
and what this does is this
allows you to bake in the color
correction
on any camera so what that means is that
i've got again this
this older camera that i use that can't
bake the footage
make the color correction directly but
if i use this i
can so now what we're going to do is
we're going to hook
this up sorry this is taking taking a
second to
hook everything up
okay monitor clean feed
record
well that's a little bit odd why isn't
that
oh i figured it out i had the the wrong
thing plugged in so this this should
immediately fix that
sdi okay sweet so now
if i go back to that image that we were
looking at earlier yeah those are my
kids actually
uh the babysitter is here right now so
if i go back to that image that we were
looking at earlier
now it looks like that so now it's
significantly
more punchy than it was before
and it basically looks like what it does
during my comedic video so let me let me
walk over here and you guys can see what
it looks like and i'm going to
adjust the lighting in the room real
quickly
so that you guys can
see see everything and i'm also going to
turn on
that mic as well hopefully hopefully
this all goes as planned
again i'm doing this live so there might
be a little couple problems but let's do
this let's try real quick
i'll bring my laptop as well or my um my
ipad so that you guys can let me know if
anything's wrong
i'm going to turn that off
okay so now it should basically look
like it normally looks like
in my oh no in my
um my comedic videos
should have been applied so and
hopefully this
yeah it looks like this mic is picking
up as well um i realize that this
mic is probably only going in in one
side i have to
adjust the settings a little bit so let
me well let me switch back
to my normal computer setup now so that
i can kind of explain things
okay so we're back i'm going to turn on
the room light one more time
okay and turn off
that mic okay so the audio should be
back to normal
do i use davinci resolve to edit your
videos too
sort of and i'm going to get to that in
a second but basically the point that
i'm trying to get to
is that
in using that sdi
to hdmi converter i actually bought
bought one with my own money the first
one blackmagic japan sent out to me
uh they lent it to me to see if i would
like it and as soon as i figured out
that it
it did the thing that i that i wanted it
to do i immediately bought one by
with my own money so they actually don't
even know that i i bought this
even though um
well i i'm using this video to kind of
talk about their various products but
it's a surprise to them that i bought
this one as well if i'd asked them for
for an additional one they probably uh
yeah where did my glasses go they
probably would have sent one out for
for free because uh they're they're a
really cool company
and i really like working with them but
essentially
again what this product does
is it takes
this this comedic image that you're
seeing on
on on this screen right now and it
changes it from
this this really really flat image that
you're currently seeing
and it turns it into that
so obviously that's a that's a really
really really big difference
and when the when the footage looks good
like this already
oh yeah egg yolchu is off i should turn
that back on
what that means is i don't have to wait
for my
my computer to process the video
so this single product that's like 150
dollars maybe it was maybe it was like
200
or so people
buy entire computers like very expensive
three thousand four thousand five
thousand dollar expensive computers
specifically to speed up the editing
process
because it takes a long time for your
computer to process the footage
but again what this device does is it it
takes care
of the processing of the color all by
itself
so you can buy this for two hundred
dollars
rather than upgrading your computer
and spending a lot of money on that and
that buying this won't speed it won't
speed up the rendering process it'll get
rid of the rendering process
entirely so this is like a game changer
this took away again about i want to say
20 or 30 minutes of work for every
single video that i make so this is a
very very
very very kind of important device
for me now i want to kind of talk about
a couple other things
real quick um
yeah so like if you don't have a lot of
money then rather than upgrading your
computer you can get one of these
to take law to take footage that
looks like
that it normally looks like this
and you can make it look like that
and get rid of that entire step
during the editing process which again
obviously is is a very very very big
deal
but now maybe what we can try and do now
is talk about the audio side of things
as well so
this camera that i'm currently shooting
on that you guys are seeing and i'm
actually going to switch the lenses back
to the other lens because this one's a
little bit
well let's just switch back for fun
okay
so this this camera
that you're currently listening to this
is
and looking at is it's called a black
magic pocket cinema camera 4k
and one of the really great things about
this camera is that it has a built-in
xlr mini input with phantom power
so one of my friends that you guys
probably know um
connor from trash taste
trash taste with with joey and gigguk
um i've been in touch with connor a fair
amount over over twitter and
we've been talking a little bit but he
saw the the office tour
um from from up close he looks shriveled
up yeah i think i need to maybe eat more
but anyway i digress connor when he
when he found out that i was using uh
blue yeti mics
he got mad at me and he said you got to
use an xlr mic and so i said okay well
give me some recommendations and so
uh he gave me some recommendations and
then
i kind of did my own research as well
and i ended up getting this camera
or this this mic up here this is called
an octava it's a russian made
condenser mic and i think that it sounds
really really good
i like kind of products that kind of
have their own unique story
so rather than getting like the
traditional road product
you know road kind of like the larger
company i went for kind of the
smaller unknown octava
russian company that sounded kind of
more i don't know
interesting to me as a creator but the
thing is with an xlr mic
like this you can't hook it up
to most cameras because most cameras
don't have
xlr inputs maybe what we can do now
actually
i'm going to switch back to this camera
and i'll show you
this camera that i'm recording at you
guys can see my setup
okay there we go
so this camera right here this black
magic pocket cinema camera 4k
this camera it does have
an xlr mini input and that means that i
can hook up this
this expensive better sounding mic
directly to my camera
and that eliminates a lot of troubles
because one of the things that i was
doing with my old camera my comedic
videos you know with with this setup
is i would record the audio and the
video
separately and then i would have to sync
them together and post and
sometimes there was weird timing issues
and i would have to go in and kind of
fix the audio and
that always took a lot of time in post
and i i didn't like it
and also as a youtuber i'll show you my
desktop
okay i think that i just kind of cut off
the stream real quick
i want to make sure that i didn't
actually hopefully this comes back real
quick
okay i think i think we're still
okay it's back yeah sorry guys i
accidentally hit the wrong button on the
on the
on the 18 mini pro and i think for a
second uh yeah the the stream cut out
but we should be back we should be good
now
but if you want to use a nice xlr mic
like this and i'll switch to my
my desktop right now my computer
as you can see like up here
i've got you know three different video
projects on my on my computer already
and that means that when i'm dropping
footage off of my camera
or off of my my microphone onto my
computer
then my desktop gets populated with
dozens and dozens and dozens of
different files so
it just makes everything more
complicated when you shoot audio and
video separately and if you shoot audio
and video together
it obviously makes things much better in
in much easier
in the post process so
using this this camera again this this
has an
xlr input now this camera
this does not have an xlr input but i
love this
this camera uh
well uh sorry this camera for my my
audio set or for my comedic videos i
really like the look of it
but i can't hook up the mic that you're
currently seeing
in that setup because that's an xlr mic
however if i switch back to here
and then earlier i showed you guys
[Music]
this thing this video assist
monitor and this
actually has xlr mini inputs on it
so by hooking up this device
to to this camera
the camera's shooting this image that i
use for my comedic videos
it allows me to add xlr
inputs
to non-xlr cameras and that's that's a
really really really big deal
so this again
this this monitor right here also has
phantom power and mini xlr inputs so you
can
you can use that to add xlr mics and
also
sdi out which is necessary for
for this product again because this is
an sdi to hdmi converter
to bake the luts into the footage but
now what we can
try and do is
let's try and make a color grade
together
so i think that this this is really
really interesting this is how i use
resolve in my setup
so we're going to go over to camera 4
and again i use
final cut pro this program it's an apple
program to
edit my videos but i use
oops this program resolve
to color grade my videos and so what
we're going to try and do now
i'm just going to move my camera down a
little bit
is we're going to try and make a color
grade and then apply it
live during this stream so
let's just delete all these
this is what the cam the footage looks
like out of my
black magic pocket cinema camera so
we're going to add a node
up here this is
um a little bit well this is this is
quite complicated
but knowing how to do this is what
enables
um i'll tell you what
we'll use this this will be easier to uh
for everyone to understand so
this is kind of close to what my footage
looks like directly out of camera
and then i increase the shadows a little
bit
and i i adjust various things
using this this tool down here
like if i do this the image gets a lot
brighter and if i pull this down the
image gets a lot darker
and then each of these nodes up here in
the right corner of the screen
they serve a purpose somewhere along the
color grading process
so this initial node is just kind of to
balance everything out
to make everything look i would say more
or less
what would you say to get
a good base to begin with and then this
node right here this adjusts uh
the the colors a little bit such that
the color balance is good
and then where things kind of start to
get a little bit complicated
is with this node right here so as you
can see right now
the only thing that's showing up on this
screen is my skin
and skin tones are very very important
uh for video and the reason for that is
if the skin tones are off like if
there's a little bit too much green
in your skin tones maybe because there
was like a green light in the room or
maybe you didn't set up your camera
properly or something like that
then it makes you look really really
sick
and so what you can do in this program
resolve
is you can very easily select
just the skin tones and then you can
you can probably see this down here but
there's a saturation
right here set to 57.50
but if i crank this up like big time or
if i bring it down all the way
now it's now it's like black and white
right
but if i bump the saturation way up then
it kind of looks like my old videos
where um the skin tone is is too
saturated
so again i set it to
for my setup uh
what was it 57.50 that's that's pretty
good
in terms of saturation for the skin
tones
and then yeah so resolve can real time
keying your face for a face tone um well
i'm not doing this this real time but
i'll i'll i'll get to that in a second
this is kind of the the general look
that i'm
creating and we're going to adjust we're
going to try and try and
apply this in a second so
this is after the skin tones have been
applied and then there's been
another adjustment to the uh to the
curves
and again these curves they basically
control how bright
the various parts of the image are so
like up here
if i bring this up this will make the
brighter
brighter parts of the image much
brighter so let's try and do that
you can see it doesn't really affect the
color of my shirt too much but like that
wall behind me
looks like way blown out now
and then likewise um this down here this
is like the darker parts of the image
the
these shadows so if i pull this
like up or down you can see that like
kind of the darker parts of the image
uh how light they are changes so
we'll just go back to that now
we're gonna i'll tell you what we'll
and then in this node this is like the
next layer
as you can see here along this
vertical line not vertical this diagonal
line
this green dot is a little bit above
this this white dot
or this this white line and that's
because i've added
green to the highlights of the image
green and also a little bit of blue
so by bringing so take a look at this
kind of the the wall again real quick
if i bring this blue up it makes the
the wall kind of blue and if i bring up
the the green again it makes the wall
kind of kind of green
so the reason that
in this setup that i'm using right now
this looks kind of like a little bit
blue
it's not from the blue the blue lights
on this camera it's because
when i made a a specific look
for this camera in resolve like i was
just showing you
i raised the highlights i raised the um
the blue and green parts of the image
such that it has kind of like an
orange and teal look to it this looks a
little bit blue now
and that is a good complementary color
with
this shirt that i'm currently wearing so
let's go back
to the to the program now and this is
the this is the thing that most people
are kind of interested in or usually are
interested in and that's the lut
so if you've done anything with uh like
video editing work or whatever
you've probably heard of a lot and for
those that don't know
it's kind of yeah yeah for like a
cyberpunk feeling
um if you a lot is kind of like a little
little tiny file that you can
add to your image to make it look like a
certain way it's
kind of like a pre-set uh
image for your video so i've currently
got this lut called
let's see 3d lut
this lut called osiris
vision six dot log that's the lot that
i'm currently using
at the end of this chain of uh
different nodes from for for my look but
if we change that lut
then what we can do
let's go to osiris and we'll we'll
choose for example
this m31 look now when i choose this
look how the image in the the upper left
side of the screen
uh changes so if i click
m31 now it was it was a minor change but
it was there so i'll kind of cycle
between the two looks right now
so by using different luts like this you
can really
change the general feel of your image
and let's let's try and do this one more
time like if i wanted a
for example like a black and white
lut a black and white look for example i
could i could choose that
or i could choose you know there are
many different pre-built luts that you
can use to make your
footage look a certain way but if i go
down to
like a different osiris [ __ ] maybe we'll
try vision
10. you know that looks a little bit
different as well
but i'll tell you what just to
illustrate kind of the power of this
this this workflow um
matt very drunk yeah lut is a lookup
table let's try and do this real
quick so as you can see right now
this is my comedic setup right
and it's this has a lot currently being
applied to it
but if i wanted to change that to
kind of a black and white style lut we
could do that so let's do that right now
in the program so i'm going to go to
luts
3d lut osiris i'm going to choose that
first
that first image and now
i think that looks pretty good in
general so what we're going to do now is
we're going to right click on this
we're going to say generate 3d lut 33
point
cube so we're going to generate we're
going to create our own lut
for this particular
style of image we're going to call it
black
and white and we'll just save it to
the pocket cinema camera file uh folder
on my desktop
now now this this is where things get
really really really cool um
let's see i'll have to
what would be the best way to do this so
i'm going to
hook up just a little basic usb
usb cable to that converter that we saw
earlier
so let's let's go down here so
i've now hooked up this device to
to my computer with just a basic usb usb
cable
and if we go back to my my monitor now
it's showing up
this is the device the sdi to hdmi 6g
and if i click down here
there's this tab for video that says
load 3d lut one or two so you can
load 3d luts onto this
this device again so what that means is
if
rather than using this comedy lut if i
if i
load a desktop pocket cinema camera
black and white
open and save now
check this out
when i go back to
this my comedic setup that lut has now
been applied to that look so i'm going
to go over there real quickly
just so you guys can see what it looks
like
so now my comedic videos so now my
comedic videos
have this black and white look applied
to them
and alt dogan is smooth as hell
he oh my god that's the same room it is
the same room
so we can very very easily
make our own custom unique look
and then choose it we'll go back to the
the comedy lot and remember
well actually we can see what this looks
like in real time so um
i'm about to open open this
oops sorry let me go back to the black
and white real quick
so as you can see the lut right now
it's the black and white test and if i
go over to
this image so you guys can't see this
because
i have to do this on my computer screen
but watch how dramatically the image
from the comedic setup changes when i
change the lut so i'm going to change
the different lut now
to the comedic lut and i'm going to
press it
now
so it takes a second to load again like
one or two seconds but now it looks a
hundred percent different than it did
before
and let's switch back real quick to the
black and white look
so we can choose we can create any kind
of look that we want for our
for our camera and we can
apply it directly to the camera using
again this this product this sdi to hdmi
converter so this isn't a
truly truly incredible um product if you
are trying to go for a specific look
um and and know a fair amount
about uh color grading and actually just
for for kicks maybe what we can do
is we'll switch back to this and
well actually yeah we'll skip that
because that'll take some additional
maybe we can try real quick
and this is this is how you turn the lot
on or off within the mini converter
so if i press if i push this
i'll tell you what we'll go back to
we'll change this camera to camera three
and we'll turn that
on okay yeah i should be able to do this
so if i
flip this little switch in this device
right now it turns
on and off the lut that's being applied
to my
my comedy camera so if i turn it off
boom
now it looks completely flat as you can
tell
and if i turn it back on
now it looks really really good so we
can choose whatever
so we can choose whatever look that we
want to create
and apply it with this mini sdi to
or yeah sdi to hdmi converter
and it's it's extremely powerful
because again you you can make
the video look like anything that you
want to and if you're a creator if
you're a youtuber like
like me you know things like color
and and the setup and making the video
look and sound aesthetically pleasing
that's that's a pretty important thing
so
and i this is again my my inner
artist uh speaking but i like my videos
to look a certain way
i like i i spent a long time making this
image look the way that it does
i spent a long time making well
naturally
this uh the comedy image look the way
that it does but
these these are the various devices that
i use to
to speed up my my workflow and do these
various things
and now i'm going to show you guys one
kind of final device and then maybe i'll
take a bunch of
questions for like an additional 30
minutes and hopefully i can answer any
anyone's questions about these specific
products
so the last product that i'm going to
show you guys is
this this and i talked about this in my
uh
room tour setup a little bit but this is
called an ultra studio recorder
3g and you can see it's got a little
thunder sign on it
this has got a thunderbolt port on it on
this side and then on this side it has
an hdmi
input and also an sdi input but what
this allows me to do
is if i you know
this camera right up here this is the
same camera the same model of camera
that i use for
this particular shot but
what i used to do and i think what most
people do
someone said is that a vape it's not
it's not a vape i don't know what you're
referring to but it's definitely not
uh most people when they shoot a youtube
video or most videos in general
they shoot it to like an sd card like
this right
and then you take this and you hook it
up to
you know like one of these adapters then
you plug this into your computer
when you plug it into your computer you
then have to transfer the files and
because the files that i work with are
prores hq files they're very very big so
every time that i create a comedic video
i end up with a file that's around 100
gigabytes because i do many many many
takes
for each line because uh i'm kind of
stupid and i can't
deliver lines properly but what that
means again is when i transfer the
footage to the computer
i have to wait about 20 minutes for the
video to
finish transferring now what i can do
instead
rather than using an sd card to transfer
the file to my desktop
if i plug this hdmi
cable that's coming out of this camera
right now if i plug
that into this port the hdmi port on
this
converter or recorder rather and then
plug this
up to my computer it allows me to save
the video directly to my computer's
desktop
so yeah it rather than having to
transfer a 100 gigabyte file from my
company
from my company camera to my computer
sorry that it allows me to save the file
directly to
my computer so the main the three maybe
four major big takeaways
take away points from this setup um and
how i use blackmagic products to edit my
videos is that
blackmagic they
well they have very professional
features in their cameras that allow you
to
create the kind of look that you want
and what i used to do is i used to
record audio and video separately
and i used to sync that up in post when
i was editing the video
and i also used to have to apply the
color grade
in post as well and that would take
about
20 minutes or 30 minutes for the
computer to process
and then finally i would have to
obviously transfer the video footage
from my camera via sd card in
one of these dongles to the computer so
that was about 20 minutes
uh 30 minutes as well and what these
various devices that i've talked about
today in today's video it allows me to
record a video that's already been color
corrected
and has the audio in the audio file in
the video file as well
it allows me to record that directly to
my desktop so these these various
products that i use
from from blackmagic they save me
at least an hour of work for every
single video that i do
and again if we go back to
the davinci resolve as well
there are just so many cool amazing
things that you can do in davinci
resolve to make your image look
exactly like you what you want it to
look like
and um
yeah i'm not a zen monk
but it is it is an ahiji lantern
um essentially these various products
allow me to really kind of uh what would
you say
well they vary they allow me to do
everything that i need in my workflow
way way way way faster than if i had
done things
kind of traditionally if i had done
things how i did when i started doing
youtube so
as a content creator i
love all these products they make my job
10
times 100 times easier than
i would say kind of the traditional
workflow when you use the sd card and
then you you color grade and in post
but again it all these products allow me
to do everything
before the footage even hits my computer
so the video is like almost
done by the time that i when i finish
hitting record
on on the camera and for those that are
just popping in right now maybe real
quick what i'll do is
i'll explain this device one more time
this is called an atem mini pro
and this is like a tiny little dedicated
computer specifically for
um oops yeah specifically
for streaming and switching cameras
so if i press two press
or press one it'll switch to this camera
and if i press two
it'll switch my main camera to that
camera and if i press three it'll switch
to that camera and if i press
four it'll switch to my desktop
but i'm also streaming directly from
this device so i'm not streaming from my
computer right now
there's an ethernet cable hooked up
directly to this device
and then this device is sending the
signal to the internet
rather than using my computer at all so
i don't have to use a program like obs
or whatever it might be to
to to send the video to the internet and
i i'm a big fan of that because i don't
like um
i don't like obs i don't like uh obs
studio any of those streaming programs
so this again this this device makes
makes my life much much easier and
the built-in you know uh switching
is really cool as well and the last
thing that i'll talk about with this
product that maybe some people are
interested in
um they offer a higher model called the
atem
mini pro iso and what that allows you to
do
is you can switch through your various
cameras like this
but then you can also save a file
a davinci resolve edit file from
the streaming device itself and that
means that
yeah yeah that means no cpu or gp
gpu load while streaming right yeah
exactly that's exactly what that means
what that means my computer i can do
anything i want on my computer because
this device is taking care of everything
involved with with the stream um
but the the higher end model it's got a
function
where you can um
switch through your various cameras
maybe if you're recording like an
interview or something and you want to
switch to
uh you know camera you wanna switch to
camera one and then you wanna switch to
camera two and then you wanna switch to
camera
three then you wanna switch to camera
four you know
that's something you would do normally
in an interview but
the higher end model it you can save
an edit file such that after you've
finished the interview
rather than having to manually go in and
sync up
all the four different video files
it the file that's saved from the
from the a to mini pro iso it will be
an edit file such that when you open it
the interview
edit file is already finished and you
just
you can just do any kind of like fine
adjustments that you want so that's
for people that do things like
interviews that's like a a game-changing
feature
so
could you do all these explanations in
japanese now
no um
i'm running out of time i've got about
20 minutes 25
20 20 to 25 minutes left uh in in the
stream but
that's how i use these various products
this blackmagic 4k cinema camera
this original pocket cinema camera this
a10 mini pro
davinci resolve and of course the video
well if i'll tell you what uh if i go
over to this camera
i can actually all angle this up
that's the camera that i shoot my
comedic videos on
and then i'll try and get out of the way
that's that's the wall back there with
with the mic and everything so
so that camera uh goes down
up in there and that's also currently
hooked up to the a2 mini pro
so that's how i use these various
products to
shoot and edit my videos in an effective
manner and get a very specific look that
i'm trying to
go for um
oh i forgot this was happening is it
staying up on youtube
after the fact um
yes this will be this video will stay up
on youtube so i'm gonna start answering
some questions now because i think that
probably a lot of people
so this
is
so it's japanese live streams time
do you know if the atem is compatible
with obs
though you don't use it having outboard
processing for compositioning
uh or compo compositioning would make my
weenie pc a lot more viable for
streaming
yes so the answer is yes the a2 mini pro
also has a usbc output on one of the
ports
so you can't see it right now because
the angle of
of this camera but this has a usbc
output and you can hook that up to your
computer
and it will show up as
a as a webcam so you can
you know open obs or obs studio or
whatever it might be
and just say choose new input
choose webcam blackmagic a10 mini pro
and you can use an a2 mini pro
within obs so the answer is yes you can
um i have no clue who you are but that
title i couldn't resist
yeah i'm uh i'm dog and i try and do
comedic styles comedic japanese videos
on on youtube
so what do you do apart from uh
youtube and and patreon
um that's basically everything that i do
i l i do a little bit of stuff with
yahoo japan but
it's almost entirely uh
youtube and patreon but someone said do
you play any video games so now i'm
going to show you guys
an additional thing real quick i'm going
to unplug
this input my
what would you say this is my well my
computer input
i'm going to unplug this real quick
we'll switch to this camera and i'm
going to unplug
the computer and this
should still be streaming hopefully
hopefully we're still good
um
yeah it looks like we're still live and
now what we're going to do
is i just plugged in my my playstation
so if we go
to
i think that was the right
plug yeah so i can also stream if i
wanted to i could stream
video games from from this setup as well
cam 4 that audio maybe i should turn
down that audio a little bit as well but
you know you can very easily stream
for example
i love i absolutely love this game final
fantasy vii so i often
play the game while i'm riding my bike
and the audio should be looks like the
audio levels are okay right now but
you can use the a to mini pro again this
device right here you can also use it as
a game capture device so right now my
playstation 4
is hooked up to this and if i press four
it'll just it'll show my playstation
and i'm still on screen
um
yes i'm just trying to look at the
comments real quick well the game's too
loud okay sorry i'll
turn that down a little bit i'll tell
you what i'll i'll mute the game and
then i'll also
i'll just switch back to this and turn
it off but yeah i play some
well i play a video game i play final
fantasy 7
because it's my favorite game and i
often use
uh well the a2 mini pro to stream to
stream the game
um dogan let's see
sorry did he just say he plays the game
while riding his bike
uh yes so i'll switch back to this this
camera real quick
um maybe you guys can see this ah this
is going to be a little bit difficult to
see but um
hopefully i can get it in the shot that
that thing right there that's an
exercise bike and i i ride that when i'm
playing final fantasy
7 because aside from video editing work
i don't have yeah stationary exercise
bike
i don't i don't have too much free time
so like right now the babysitter's here
um one other maybe cool thing that you
guys might be interested in with the a10
mini pro
is that you can also change the
input for your monitor so like
this this right now this is kind of like
the program set up but like if i
if i want to only see like my
playstation
um i can do that if i want to see
only you know my my comedic camera i can
do that i can switch between
any of these uh different cameras but
for
when streaming it's it's typically best
to
i feel use this this particular menu
because you can really see
well each of the different cameras you
can see what's going on and you can also
you know seem like you can see like the
data rate for the stream looks like i'm
on
air you know it's doing well
so yeah that's that's another kind of
cool feature about the a10 mini pro you
can choose
the output hdmi signal of the device as
well
so is it possible to raise a family
comfortably with patreon
and youtube um i've done pretty well
with
my patreon series so we're right now
things are going well but
um you know it's obviously different
from from each person
i for a very long time i had to work two
job well
kind of three jobs i did the youtube
videos i did my full-time job at apu
and then i also did the patreon
phonetics lessons like this
and then after about two or three years
of grinding and you know working
two two three one two jobs i guess full
time
i finally got to a point where i could
stop working at apu
and just concentrate on the youtube side
of things so um
are you going to the university today no
i no longer work at the university so
when will you start your vtuber career
uh
that's a yeah um we're gonna have to
figure out exactly
what uh mixer that harris heller was
using in that that recent video that he
did and once i figured that out then uh
i should be able to make um
my my v tuber debut
um does anyone have any other other
additional questions
uh about
again streaming or
any of the various camera products that
i use again i'm
hooked up right now to four different
cameras on this stream
and i've got my playstation hooked up as
well but the audio for that is off so it
should be okay
and then i'm using this product the a10
mini pro to cycle between everything so
i can
really easily use this to oops to
effectively live stream we'll switch
back to that
nice transition and turn that off so
yeah
how much does this whole setup cost
that's a really good question
so um i found that
for me it's better to buy things used
so like i bought this
this camera this is like this camera
came out in 2013 so like a lot of people
right now
on on on the internet they're talking
about like this new sony a7 iii
uh and like the canon i think it's the
canon eos r
like these are like two thousand three
thousand dollar five thousand dollar
cameras that shoot like 8k
video this camera came out in
2013 and it's only 1080p but the quality
is insane and i bought it used for
i think like 400 um i guess
maybe it was 500 and then this lens on
top of it
this was uh it was literally a hundred
dollars
so if you know enough about the
equipment that you're buying
you can use cheap equipment
cheap but good equipment to get similar
results
again this camera right here that i use
for my
for my comedic videos i also bought this
camera used um
same exact camera as as
as this literally the exact same camera
and um that was also about 500
used so i buy all my lenses used i buy
all my cameras used um
and then the uh did it where was it
[Music]
i guess maybe it was over here yeah
then this little device the sdi to hdmi
converter
this was like 200 so rather than buying
a really really expensive computer
i bought this and i don't have to do
color correction in my videos i don't
have to render my videos
so rather than buying again like a four
or five thousand dollar computer i
bought this thing for two hundred
dollars and i i eliminate the
rendering process entirely so
um obviously i've got many different
cameras going going right here
and like this camera right here uh
this camera blackmagic japan lent me
this camera because they learned that i
shoot everything
on blackmagic and we're currently kind
of working together they're
lending me some products i'm doing some
pr for them because i
love their products as i talked about at
the beginning of this video so
um let's see
will this stream be up later yes um
it's so crazy to see this dude in a
different shirt yeah
with all the video i'm processing do you
have a large amount of storage for
archiving
roughly how much yeah so i have a
network attached
storage and that has i think 16
terabytes i bought that fairly recently
um
but you know a network attached storage
is not that expensive like you can get a
decent
uh network attached storage for much
cheaper than buying like a very very
fast ssd for your computer
but uh yeah i use a synology network
attached storage
um let's see
if you guys want to see something kind
of funny this this desk that i'm using
right now
this is also it's a standing desk and
because my camera is mounted to it if i
press the button
it looks really really smooth when i
raise it up so
oh
oops
so see you guys later
and i'll just i'll bring it back down to
the uh to the normal setting
elevator um
where did you get your used camera um i
bought both of my
used cameras on amazon japan
but i mean you can buy these things used
online on like ebay or
or even amazon uh in the states
for again like four four hundred dollars
five hundred dollars
i've seen them as cheap as like three
hundred dollars and they're
incredible cameras again they came out
in 2013
but they still have i think in my
opinion they their image still looks
much more cinematic than like
99 of the cameras that are currently out
so
uh yeah b h photo b h photo would also
have
uh have these devices um are you a prime
member
uh yeah i'm an amazon prime member
um let's see do you plan on changing
your blue yetis for xlr mics yeah so i i
addressed this earlier in the video but
um connor from trash taste he learned
that i was using
uh black magic or not black magic uh
blue yeti mics
and he got upset with me and he said you
got to get a proper xlr mic so
recently i upgraded um this camera or
this this mic up here this is
uh it's called the octava mk12 i think
is what it's called
um and that's a an xlr mic and then this
this camera that's in the middle of the
screen right now
well this camera that i'm pointing at
this has a mini
a mini xlr input built into it so that i
can hook up
a nice xlr mic like this directly to my
camera and that's
again if you know a fair amount about
video or audio you know that that's a
that's that's a very very big deal so
oops okay um
yeah of course it was conor that
suggested it
yeah connor and dogan collab when um
be on the lookout that's all i can say
okay how do you manage all the clips a
few days of shooting
and so many files i started tagging but
it's getting a bit overwhelming
well for me
what would you say file organization
is very very easy because i essentially
only have two setups i have
my comedy setup this setup and then i
have my desk set up
this this camera right so as long as the
as i as long as i name the files
properly like
you know 34 signs you're in japan.mov
file organization is really easy i'm not
like
you know many of my youtube friends for
example
like connor or like uh chris broad
abroad in japan
um you know they make videos where they
go
out go out outside go out in the town
and they they shoot like
hours and hours of footage and then they
they choose between all the different
takes
and that's really hard to organize all
that footage but
my all my footage is always one single
giant file so i don't have to worry
about organization basically
okay are you going to be on the trash
taste
podcast we'll see
we'll see
do you have any tech that was bought new
um
well my camera or my uh not my camera my
my computer i bought my imac new and i
bought
uh my ipad pro
so i'm reading the comments right now
off of
off of this ipad pro
down here i bought this new and then
again i bought my computer
new but again most of the tech that i
buy
is used and it's blackmagic products
like
again this blackmagic pocket cinema
camera 4k
and blackmagic products are notoriously
cheap for the feature set that they
provide so again
i'm kind of repeating myself at this
point but this camera right here
when this came out in 2013 for
for a thousand dollars is i think the
price that it was announced at
it was like five thousand dollars
cheaper than any other
camera that had the same um feature set
because no other cameras at that time
could shoot raw for less than again like
ten thousand dollars so
it was really really unheard of and
that's one of the reasons i love their
products
i love their company so much is because
rather than trying to kind of just sit
back on a working model
um like well i don't want to name any
other companies but
rather than just getting money from
what's already out there and not
innovating
blackmagic has always said okay uh we're
not gonna wait we're gonna
immediately upgrade or release this new
this new gear that's even
even more crazy even though the other
camera companies probably won't release
it for another like three or four years
so recently
they just released a um a 12k
camera for example and
you you know no other camera company is
going to release a 12k
camera for for a long time i think
that's that's overkill obviously
i only shoot my videos in 1080p
sometimes 4k but
they bring incredible features for an
extremely
extremely priced because they just want
as many people as possible to have
as many and well what would you say
as much technology as possible to enable
them to create the videos
that they like with as with as little
friction as possible so again that's
that's why i like the company one of the
reasons i like the company so much
um
uh let's see
can you go more in depth about how you
reduced noise in your setup you said the
echoes were pretty bad
um how about noise from outside well in
my room so
rather than spending you know like six
hundred dollars on like a
assure sm sm7b which is a really
expensive mic
i bought a like a 200 mic a much much
cheaper mic
and then i i did i got like these
amazon sound panels and i covered my
room with them
because it's better to have a it's much
better to have
a room that's been sound treated with a
decent mic
than it is to have a room that's been
that hasn't been sound treated with a
bad mic so
um let's see i have the lumix
it seems pretty good as a camera it can
shoot 4k and i got it used with
a bag for like 300 euros bro why would
anyone need a 12k
camera so the reason
well the same reason that anyone would
want an 8k camera or a 4k
camera for that matter is because when
you have those additional pixels
it means that you can deliver like if
you frame the shot a little bit wrong
or if you want to zoom into part of the
image after the fact
if you zoom in it won't be pixely so if
you're
shooti it well it's a professional
camera that 12k one that's for like
movies right where they have like a
fifty thousand dollar budget budget for
the camera
but like if if you're filming a movie
and you're paying
the actor millions of dollars um
then you need the ability to um
zoom in or or you know change
where the the framing of the image
after the fact and that's what that's
what 12k or 8k
or again 4k does
so that's what the extra resolution
would do in most movies i would say are
probably
delivered in in 8k
so having 12k allows you to
de it gives you flexibility with 8k
the same way that having 4k gives you
flexibility with 1080p so
um bro that video with harris was so
expected
how'd that happen oh thank you xavier by
the way for
for the donation your thoughts on modern
japanese possibly becoming
its own language in the future um
well i think just
modern japanese is going to have more
and more and more and more english load
loanwords over time and eventually
probably like i don't know 100 years or
yeah probably about 100 years in japan
it's going to be like in like singapore
where people regularly switch between
like chinese and english or i know that
i'm pretty sure they do that in was it
the philippines
uh with spain and tagalog
spanish and tagalog sorry if i'm getting
the languages mixed up but
i think that um yeah in like 100 years
people will
just kind of freely freely switch
between japanese and english
probably rather than
and also that japanese will probably
have a lot of loan words but
yeah um
i got to go in two minutes does anyone
have any
uh any kind of final
questions that i can answer about my
camera setup again i'm using this
this a-10 mini pro down here to
currently
stream this uh this video to youtube
and i've got four different inputs my
comedic setup i've got my
this camera i've got this camera
shooting this and then i've got my well
i've got my playstation hooked up
because i was showing showing that a
little bit earlier as well but
i'm streaming currently with the a10
mini pro it's an amazing device for
streaming and for
i would say content creators in general
what's the next camera you want to buy
i'm not going to get another camera
i don't need another camera the cameras
that i have right now
are more than enough and i think that as
a writer
it's much more important that i
concentrate on
my writing than trying to get like a a
4k
camera or like an 8k camera or you know
anything like that i just need to
concentrate on my writing
and use these these great products like
you know this
nine-year-old camera to deliver my
my writing because even this
nine-year-old black magic
camera it's overflowing with features
that you know most creators can even
take advantage of because they're so
powerful
um atem better than stream deck i like
the atem
because you can use it as a mini
streaming computer
whereas the stream deck it's kind of
like a uh what would you say it's a
device that'll
allows you to do different things within
a program like obs but with this stream
deck oops
down here i'm not using obs right now
i'm streaming directly from this device
there's an ethernet cable going directly
into this device
so that's why i really like the atem
more than the uh
uh what was it the uh the elgato
stream stream link stream deck
yeah nine year old camera brofist yeah
so this is a nine-year-old camera that i
bought used
this is nine-year-old camera that i
bought used
blackmagic japan was gracious enough to
lend me this camera this 4k
blackmagic pocket cinema camera and i
talked about that at the beginning of
the stream but
blackmagic technology the things that
they make they're so
they're overflowing with technology so
like they're
this camera this 4k blackmagic pocket
cinema camera
this has so many features you don't need
to worry about getting like a 2 000 or 3
000
camera if you're trying to start youtube
like if you get this camera or even
even this older camera again this was
like 400 dollars
used you're set i use a 400 camera this
camera to shoot all my
my youtube videos so
um okay so i got to get going it's
currently uh
501 so um
i unfortunately don't have affiliate
links but i've linked all of the
blackmagic products that i talked about
today
in the video description for this video
so you can go ahead and check that out
um dog and go to save 10
unfortunately not but uh i got to get
going guys right now